here who actually met Muhammad Ali as a
child and you can hopefully see here in
the book this is you Michael yeah and
tell me what do you remember it that day
it was just so exciting everywhere he
went the whole school followed him he
was just so nice to everyone like he
said he never looked down on the people
who looked up to him never did how much
of an inspiration do you think he's
proved to be his boxing you could just
do a whole interview on just his boxing
you see one thing but Daniel matters
humanitarian even better the times when
you didn't go to Vietnam a lot of people
thought there was time a rough but we
double life he's the bomb this is a man
who crafts in an entire life around
fighting this man but was a pacifist
male there's not a contradiction you
think that that's still exciting it's
the whole person usually well then you
gotta be rough sometimes but you got to
have a son if you're gonna have a soul
it's a wrap and how did you feel when
you heard the news and you thought back
to that day it was just like Prince when
I woke up they say person's dead I was
like no and then like double no double
thing like all the good people are going
to soon and you're so close to him there
in that image one of many failings one
of many many fans What did he say to you
keep your hand up stay strong now if you
wanted a real story here's a story ain't
your hunger strike I leave used to have
a school on 18th in Mohammad Ali then I
leave school boxing I was teaching our
serving one day so he came to school Oh
chapter the chapter and so days like
does anybody have questions for the
champ he said what I was like champ how
do you keep power in your jab and keep
speeding at the same time he said hold
your hand up and I did like it
this guy this guy got power in his jab
that's who no that's not real that's
like wow they say either win hard but
they didn't feel my head that's come to
share their stories that memory of
Muhammad Ali the greatest of all time
and that's what we see across Louisville
the goats go everybody else's second go
third goat the goat the original
greatest of all time and of course
impossible to imitate you can go inside
inside the museum and see and try and
shadowbox with him but no one comes
watch your eyes instructor the first
thing I tell my students learn his ring
movement that's first learned a circle
movement that's the best movement nobody
can be just ring movement even has a
pair of his gloves in his pride ambition
England his office this that might be
the most famous of the picture from what
I see how do you measure his
contribution in terms of his activism
how do you think he's changed not only
do we have in America Wow youth he
changed the world
he's drove them he's a global man you
see one thing he didn't put nobody down
I won't talk politics if I'm never going
to bother he loved everybody you could
just know like this guy it's different
the only thing I do explain cuz you just
have to feel his his his back he had a
fire oh all the time
but he's at the same time he was so open
to everyone that's what I liked about
and as a small boy there did you go home
thinking differently about you what you
wanted from your life a fleeting hill I
want to learn like him I wanted to learn
how to defend myself that's why I ended
up teaching Chinese boxing so in many
ways that meaning now how are we even
not facing maybe 14 maybe 14 so he
really yeah affected the career darling
35 times in the Western California
Community Center on the back of a
flatbed truck
just giving away to Quran just so many
different times and it's an interfaith
service that he's going to be holding
does it surprise you that he chose to do
that not at all it would be strange if
he didn't that was his parting message
me and his family of course are now in
town and we're expecting his body to
return what scenes do you think we're
going to see next Friday there's gonna
be so many celebrities dignitaries
congressman it's gonna be stuck the
president's coming so we're probably
over on the other side of jaffers just
peeking and waving called the
dignitaries that take over it always
happens like that like when Brandon
Angelina was at the dinner I was way
over there waving the president has said
that he could be careless with his words
you know everybody younger different
stages of their lives said he was to it
everybody no eating were to it as he
grew so not being careless was saying
there's a chance at that time
Michael Callan thank you very much
indeed for sharing those memories Thank
You England you know our young as you
can see there are incredibly passionate
stories and so many people who speak to
have actually come into contact with
Muhammad Ali in some way and he used to
come to the center here and he'd sit
down and actually watch himself back and
those big famous boxing matches because
he used to enjoy his legacy his
contribution whether it was his words or
his battles